The Joe Rogan experience.
Yeah. I love Uber.
I wonder how much that's preventing drunk
driving. I just had this conversation.
Yeah. I think what, you know,
mothers against drunk driving mad,
you know, maybe even the government
should like kick in and go like, you know,
these guys are saving lives.
Yeah. For sure. If you get,
cause if you're not doing that, then
you're drinking and driving most likely,
most likely. So it gives you a
real easy option. Yeah. Yeah.
And it's so quick. It's so convenient.
You don't have to pull cash out. It's,
it's great. It's kind of a weird
organization of both of them.
It's like they're trying to figure
out if their employees, right.
With their contractors.
Yeah.
And then there's like this fact that
you're just getting into someone's car,
you don't know them. Yeah. Yeah. I
mean you assume that if you get a limo,
but there's a background check, right.
If you get a cab, you living on the edge.
Right. That's how I was going to say.
If he never know exactly. Robert Deniro,
a hundred people looking at
me. Yeah. That's all. I'm
going to fucking psychopath.
Right. That's what you'd like. But you
would get like New York City cab driver,
he'd get characters and you get either
like a angry white dudes or like a guys
who come from other countries. I
can tell you cool stories. Yeah.
You get like characters, weird smells and
shit. Crazy smells, lots of weird music.
Possibly a Voodoo doll,
but now you know what you get when
you get in New York City cab driver,
you get advertisements and you'd screens
like they have little laptops facing.
Yeah,
and the play these these credit card
machine back there and they play these,
these videos about things
about restaurants and this
and that shows that's its
own network at this point. Yeah, like
just the cab network. It is kind of right.
It must be, yeah. I've seen that.
Probably has their own little loop that
they pledged Jimmy Fallon and I mean
I've seen him down there
many times doing stuff.
I remember they used to do that HBO
show Taxi Cab Confessions. Yeah.
That was crazy. I enjoyed that. I was
like, Hula Fuck is signing this release.
We've given these people. It's
like, I just want to be on TV.
And I would say the worst stuff,
like if you're fucked up on coke and
you get into a a cab and you start just
talking shit about all the crazy
sexual stuff that you like, and then,
and then afterwards they're like, hey,
you're going to be on HBO. You're like,
fuck yeah, I'm inside that thing. And
then you wake up in the morning. No,
that's true. Call doing that. This,
this waiver at the right time. Yeah,
that's gold. That's a good move.
How does that work?
Does that mean to you if you're hammered,
I,
there's gotta be some loophole.